All of us have regrets, a business that fails, a degree we never finished, or a friendship we let fade away. Sometimes we make choices we regret, while other times we regret the choices we didn't make or the paths we didn't pursue. Regret can be painful. Who doesn't know the sinking feeling that comes with saying, if only I hadn't done that? But some psychologists believe that regret can also be productive. By learning from our regrets rather than dwelling on them, we can make needed changes in our lives and set ourselves up to make better decisions in the future. So what's the difference between productive and unproductive regret? Why do some people seem to ruminate on their regrets more than others?
我们所有人都有遗憾，比如失败的商业投资、未完成的学位，或者一段渐渐疏远的友情。有时我们会对做出的选择感到后悔，而有时我们则对没有做出的选择或没有追求的道路感到遗憾。遗憾可能会带来痛苦。谁没体验过那种说出“我要是当初没那样做就好了”时带来的失落感呢？但一些心理学家认为，遗憾也可以是具有建设性的。通过从遗憾中吸取教训而不是深陷其中，我们能够在生活中做出必要的改变，并为自己在未来做出更好的决定做好准备。那么，建设性遗憾与非建设性遗憾有什么区别？为什么有些人似乎比其他人更容易反复咀嚼自己的遗憾？
If regret is consuming your thoughts, what can you do about it? And in this age of social media and fear of missing out, do people have more regrets than they used to? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Robert Leahy, founder and director of the American Institute for Cognitive Therapy in New York City, and a clinical professor of psychology in the Department of Psychiatry at Wild Cornell Medical College. He is the past president of the Association for Behavioral and Cognitive Therapies, the International Association of Cognitive Psychotherapy, and the Academy of Cognitive Therapy.
如果遗憾正蚕食着你的思绪，你能做些什么？在这个社交媒体盛行、害怕错过的时代，人们的遗憾是否比过去更多了？欢迎收听《心理学说话》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是罗伯特·莱希博士，他是纽约市认知疗法美国研究所的创始人和主任，也是康奈尔大学医学院精神病学系的心理学临床教授。他曾担任行为与认知疗法协会、国际认知心理疗法协会以及认知疗法学会的主席。
Dr. Leahy is the author or editor of 29 books for clinicians and the general public. His latest book is called If Only, Finding Freedom from Regret, and it is all about learning to understand regret and make it a tool for self-knowledge and change. Dr. Leahy, thank you for joining me. Well, thank you, Kim, for having me, and I hope you don't regret having me on the show. I don't think I will. Let's talk about what we mean by regret. Is regret an emotion, a way of thinking, a little of both?
莱希博士是面向临床医生和普通公众的 29 本书的作者或主编。他的最新著作名为《要是当初：如何摆脱遗憾的束缚》，这本书主要讲述了如何学会理解遗憾，并将其作为实现自我认知和改变的工具。莱希博士，感谢您做客我们的节目。很高兴你能邀请我，金，我希望你不要为邀请我上节目而感到后悔。我想我不会的。我们来谈谈我们所说的遗憾是什么意思。遗憾是一种情绪、一种思维方式，还是两者的结合？
Well, it's a little about, both, you know, regret is certainly a way of thinking. It's a sense of emotion of disappointment or remorse or sadness about an action taken or not taken or what we might anticipate we might feel if we take an action or do not take an action. So it's both cognitive and emotional. And the thing it's interesting about regret, Kim, is that, you know, in the clinical literature, there really is very little on regret that I came across in my reading. I mean, there's a lot on regret in behavioral economics, decision-making decision processes. But it's the second most commonly mentioned emotion in conversations that colloquially. students have, love being the first. So it's a pervasive emotion.
嗯，这在一定程度上两者兼有，你知道的，遗憾当然是一种思维方式。它是一种对已采取或未采取的行动，或者对我们预期采取或不采取行动时可能会有的感受所产生的失望、懊悔或悲伤的情绪。所以它既是认知的，也是情感的。关于遗憾，有趣的地方在于，金，在临床文献中，我在阅读时其实很少遇到关于遗憾的内容。我的意思是，在行为经济学和决策制定、决策过程中，有很多关于遗憾的研究。但在日常交谈中，它却是被提及频率第二高的情绪，爱情排在第一位。所以这是一种无处不在的情绪。
It's often an emotion that people ruminate about an emotion that can linger on sometimes for decades. I mean, I've talked to people in their 90s who regret decisions they made when they were in their 20s. So it's a fascinating emotion and looking forward to talking about it today. Well, what's the difference between productive and unproductive regret? Right. A lot of people, especially on social media where there's always the power of positive thinking
它往往是一种让人反复咀嚼的情绪，一种有时会持续数十年的情绪。我的意思是，我跟一些九十多岁的老人交流过，他们依然对二三十岁时做出的决定感到后悔。所以这是一个令人着迷的情绪，我很期待今天能探讨这个话题。那么，建设性遗憾和非建设性遗憾有什么区别？没错。很多人，尤其是总是推崇积极思维力量的社交媒体上……
and all, regret is, it's an emotion, like all emotions evolved because they were adaptive. So how can regret be adaptive? It certainly can be maladaptive. It can lead to rumination, depression, self-criticism, resentment. But it can be adaptive if you use it in the right way. So, for example, productive regret would be an ability to learn from my mistakes or to anticipate learning from my mistakes. So, for example, if you ask young people to think about what they're going to live on when they're in their 60s toward the end of their working career, how much money they're going to have, that increase. is planned savings.
总之，遗憾是一种情绪，像所有情绪一样，它们的进化是因为它们具有适应性。那么，遗憾怎么会具有适应性呢？它当然也可能是适应不良的。它会导致反刍思维、抑郁、自我批判和怨恨。但如果你以正确的方式使用它，它就能发挥适应性作用。例如，建设性的遗憾意味着能够从我的错误中吸取教训，或者预期自己能从错误中吸取教训。举个例子，如果你让年轻人去思考他们六十多岁、接近职业生涯末期时靠什么生活，他们会有多少存款，这会增加有计划的储蓄。
Half the people, for example, who are prescribed medication for hypertension a year or later, don't take the medication. But if you ask them to think about what their life would be like if they have a stroke and they're paralyzed or unable to speak, whatever, that significantly increases the compliance with medication. So regret can be used productively. if you look back and you think, gee, you know, what did I do that in the future I might do differently? That's like a self-correction type thing.
例如，有一半被开具高血压药物处方的人在一年或更久之后没有按时服药。但如果你让他们想象一下，如果自己中风导致瘫痪或无法说话，生活会变成什么样，这会显著提高他们对服药的依从性。因此，如果你回过头去想：“天哪，我做了什么，以后可能会做得不一样呢？”这种遗憾就能被建设性地利用。这就像是一种自我纠正类的机制。
Unproductive regret or maladaptive regret is characterized not by self-correction, but by self-criticism. And in fact, in some cases, self-loathing self-hatred. It's unproductive regrets characterized by dwelling on it over and over and over. over and not viewing it as an opportunity to learn from experience. I mean, if you think about regret as, you know, you carried out an experiment, you did something or you chose not to do something and you're not satisfied with the consequences. Well, we as psychologists are always carrying out experiments, but we and our ordinary lives carry out experiments.
非建设性遗憾或适应不良的遗憾，其特点不是自我纠正，而是自我批判。事实上，在某些情况下，还伴随着自我厌恶和自我痛恨。非建设性遗憾的特点是一次又一次、反反复复地纠结于其中，而不把它视为从经验中学习的机会。我的意思是，如果你把遗憾看作是：你做了一项实验，你做了一些事或者选择不做某些事，但你对结果不满意。好吧，我们作为心理学家总是在做实验，但我们在日常生活中其实也一直在做实验。
You know, you carry out the experiments of bringing up the most provocative political statement on Thanksgiving dinner with your family. And you find out that that experiment didn't work very well. What did you learn from that experiment? You know, what's interesting to me is there are some people who don't seem to learn from their mistakes or don't anticipate their mistakes. So, for example, people who abuse drugs, who overreach, who don't take their medication, who engage in unsafe sex, who say inappropriate things, they don't seem to anticipate the regret. They're not using what I would call prospective regret or anticipatory regret in a useful way. People who are manic who think they can do anything, that they have all the powers in the world,
你知道的，你在感恩节的家庭晚宴上抛出了一个极具挑衅性的政治言论，这就是你在做的实验。然后你发现这个实验效果并不好。你从那个实验中学到了什么？你知道的，让我觉得有趣的是，有些人似乎没有从错误中吸取教训，也没有预见到自己的错误。例如，那些滥用药物、好高骛远、不按时吃药、进行不安全隐患的性行为、说不当言论的人，他们似乎没有预见到遗憾。他们没有以一种有用的方式使用我所说的“前瞻性遗憾”或“预期性遗憾”。那些处于躁狂状态的人，觉得自己无所不能，拥有世上所有的力量……
and they're too sexy for their own clothes. And, you know, they're just, they don't anticipate regret. They're a little bit too over the top with their confidence. So it's an important thing to use regret productively. And I think the most economical way, Kim, to use regret is to use the regrets of other people. I know when I was in my early 20s, a lot of my age peers were misusing drugs or misusing alcohol. And I thought, you know, gee, the only thing I really have of any value because I had no money, I was on a fellowship. The only thing I have any value is my brain.
觉得自己迷人得衣衫都快包不住了。你知道的，他们就是……他们没有预见到遗憾。他们的自信心有点过头了。所以，建设性地利用遗憾是一件很重要的事。我认为，金，利用遗憾最经济的方式就是利用别人的遗憾。我知道在我二十出头的时候，我许多同龄人都在滥用药物或酗酒。当时我想，你知道的，我真正有价值的东西只有我的大脑——因为我没有钱，靠奖学金过活。我唯一有价值的东西就是我的大脑。
I'm not going to endanger my brain or my health like some of these people have. So it's using the regrets of other people in a productive way by learning from their mistakes. So there is a kind of inoculation then for certain people if you're capable of visualizing what your future might be like if you did something or didn't do something. Exactly. Exactly. I like the word inoculation cam. That's great. You know, it's kind of like, like, you know, there's a lot of talk about living in the present moment, you know, which sounds so comfortable. but the only creature that lives entirely in the present moment is a mosquito. So I like to think about living in all the moments of my life, you know, thinking about what I did when I was younger, the mistakes I made, the things I did right, but also thinking about my future self.
我不会像这些人那样拿自己的大脑或健康去冒险。因此，这是通过吸取他人的教训，以一种建设性的方式利用他人的遗憾。那么，如果你有能力想象出自己做或不做某事时未来会是什么样子，这其实就相当于对某些人的一种接种？没错。没错。我很喜欢“接种”这个词，金。这太棒了。你知道的，这有点像……人们经常谈论活在当下，听起来多么舒适啊，但唯一完全活在当下的生物是一只蚊子。所以我更喜欢思考我生命中的所有时刻，你知道的，想想我年轻时做过的事、犯过的错误、做对了的事，同时也想想未来的自己。
So, for example, one of the techniques that we use in cognitive behavior therapy is ask yourself, what would your future self say? I've often do role plays with patients. You know, so what would your future self say about over drinking or, you know, or trying to malign your boss or, you know, spending all this money or whatever it is? What would your future self say? Not your immediate self, your future self. Because your future self may be the wise And that's something that I think that's something that people often don't recognize that consequences will follow from actions that you take or do not take. Is there a difference in the degree of regret between something that you've done and regretting
所以，例如，我们在认知行为疗法中使用的技巧之一就是问自己：未来的你会怎么说？我经常和患者进行角色扮演。你知道的，对于过度饮酒、或者试图中伤老板、或者花光所有钱等等行为，未来的你会怎么说？未来的你会怎么说，而不是眼前的你。因为未来的你可能更有智慧。我认为人们往往意识不到这一点：你采取或不采取的行动都会带来相应的后果。在你做过的事带来的遗憾和未做的事带来的遗憾之间，也就是“未选择的路”，它们的遗憾程度是否存在差异？
something that you didn't do, you know, the road not taking? Sure. Is one type of regret more difficult to learn from than the other? Well, it's interesting because in the short term, we tend to have more hot regret or emotional intensity of regret for actions taken. So we may be correct that if we take this action, we may immediately after have some regrets. For example, buyer's remorse, you buy a car or you buy an apartment or a house. A very common thing is right after you think, what was I thinking? You know, I'm putting all this money down, whatever.
当然。其中一种类型的遗憾是不是比另一种更难从中吸取教训？嗯，这很有趣，因为在短期内，对于已经采取的行动，我们往往会有更多的“热烈遗憾”或强烈的情感遗憾。因此我们的直觉可能是对的：如果我们采取了这种行动，紧接着我们可能会感到一些遗憾。例如，买家悔恨，你买了一辆车、一套公寓或一栋房子。非常常见的情况是，买完之后你马上就会想：“我刚才在想什么？我把这么多钱投进去了……”等等。
So this is called the action effect. You know, we have more regrets for action taken in the short term. But in the long term, as people look back on their lives, they tend to regret what they did not do. And this is true cross-culturally in other cultures that have been studied. We tend to regret things we did not to. We did not pursue that course of action or that education or that relationship or that investment. So that tends to be less of an intense, passionate regret. It tends to be more of a kind of.
所以这被称为“行动效应”。在短期内，我们会对已经采取的行动产生更多遗憾。但从长远来看，当人们回首往事时，他们往往会为自己没有做的事感到遗憾。在其他被研究过的文化中，这种跨文化的现象也是真实存在的。我们往往会为自己没有做的事感到遗憾。我们没有追求那种行动、那种教育、那种关系或那项投资。因此，这种遗憾往往不是那种强烈的、充满激情的情感，它往往更像是一种……
lingering, unpleasant feeling. But people can ruminate about that for months, years, decades. Well, let's talk about ruminating for a minute because some people seem to get really stuck dwelling on their regrets and living and reliving what they did or didn't do. Are there some personality characteristics that lead some people to experience more regret or more painful regret? Sure. Yeah.
挥之不去的不快感觉。但人们可能会为此反复琢磨数月、数年甚至数十年。好吧，我们来谈谈反刍思维，因为有些人似乎真的陷入了对遗憾的纠结中，不断生活在过去并反复回味他们做过或没做过的事。是否存在某些人格特征，导致某些人经历更多的遗憾或更痛苦的遗憾？当然。是的。
So we know that rumination is a fundamental part of depression. And in fact, the research by the late Nolan Oxima at Yale shows that people who ruminate are more likely to get depressed and stay depressed. Having said that, in terms of tying in regret with rumination, there are certain ways of looking at the world that lead to more rumination. One is to have inflexible expectations that this is what I accept. expected. It wasn't what turned out. And so I'm going to just dwell on it. The other is the tendency to not accept tradeoffs. So in my view, like I live in New York City and I know Kim, you live in New York City at one time. So when you live in New York City, you've got to accept tradeoffs. I mean, even standing for an elevator is a major tradeoff negotiation.
我们知道反刍思维是抑郁症的一个根本部分。事实上，已故的耶鲁大学学者诺兰·霍克西玛的研究表明，有反刍思维倾向的人更容易患上抑郁症并且长期无法走出抑郁。话虽如此，如果把遗憾与反刍思维联系起来，确实存在某些看待世界的方式会导致更多的反刍。其中之一就是抱有不灵活的期望，认为事情“本该如此”。但结果并非如此。因此我就会对此耿耿于怀。另一种倾向是无法接受权衡取舍。在我看来，比如我住在纽约市，我知道金你曾经也住在纽约市。所以在纽约市生活，你必须接受权衡取舍。我的意思是，就连排队等电梯都是一场重大的权衡博弈。
You know, so. Where's my closet? Where's my backyard? Right, right. Exactly. When people get married, they end up getting divorced over closet space, not over arguments. But, you know, it's, some people have a hard time. accepting trade-offs.
你知道的……我的衣橱在哪里？我的后院在哪里？对的，对的。没错。当人们结婚时，他们最后往往会因为衣橱空间不足而闹离婚，而不是因为原则问题吵架。但你知道的，有些人就是很难接受权衡取舍。
It's kind of like there are two ways of thinking that I think contribute to rumination and regret. One is I call pure mind that my mind should be pure. So, for example, I should never be ambivalent. For example, I was talking with a young man who had been dating and actually living with this woman for several years. And he said, I don't know, how can I get married if I have mixed feelings? So he equated ambivalence with it's not a good decision. And I said, well, first of all, the word decision in Latin means to cut away from. And it means that you have mixed feelings.
这就好比有两类思维方式我认为助长了反刍和遗憾。其中之一我称之为“纯洁心灵”，即我的内心必须是纯洁的。例如，我绝不能产生矛盾心理。举个例子，我曾和一个年轻男子交谈过，他和这个女人约会并同居了好几年。他说：“我不知道，如果我有矛盾复杂的情感，我怎么能结婚呢？”因此，他把矛盾心理等同于“这不是一个好决定”。我说：“首先，‘决定’（decision）这个词在拉丁语中的意思是‘切除、割舍’。这意味着你确实会有复杂矛盾的感受。”
That's what a decision is. Right. Second, one reason you have mixed feelings is that you know each other, right? I mean, Romano and Julia is a wonderful fantasy story. but it would not be a great way of basing your future commitment to your life partner. Within five days, there are several people dead, including Romay-owned Juliet, based on a glance at a party without any conversation at the time. So ambivalence may be a sign of reality testing rather than the idea that my mind should be absolutely pure,
这就是决定的含义。其次，你会有矛盾感受的原因之一，正是因为你们彼此了解，对吧？我的意思是，《罗密欧与朱丽叶》是一个极好的幻想故事，但这绝不是为你未来对生活伴侣的承诺奠定基础的好方法。短短五天内，几个人就丧命了，包括罗密欧和朱丽叶，而这一切仅仅源于派对上的一瞥，当时甚至都没有交谈过。因此，矛盾心理可能是现实检验的标志，而不是说“我的内心必须绝对纯洁，
my emotion should always be positive. We have to recognize that life is filled with complexity and nuance, and that ambivalence is simply a recognition and honest recognition of that. It's like Salieri, the famous composer around the time of Mozart, said too many notes. But, you know, Mozart had just the right of notes, the right number of notes, whatever. We know that now. Yeah, he's pretty good, that Mozart guy.
我的情绪必须永远是积极的”。我们必须认识到，生活充满复杂性和细微差别，而矛盾心理不过是对这种复杂性的一种承认，一种诚实的承认。就像莫扎特那个时代的著名作曲家萨列里所说的那样：“音符太多了。”但是，你知道的，莫扎特的音符恰到好处，音符数量正合适。我们现在知道了这一点。是的，那个叫莫扎特的家伙确实挺厉害的。
Maybe not as great as Taylor Swift, but you can't have everything in life. But so ambivalence, the intolerance of ambivalence contributes to regret and rumination. In any decision, you know, people think about what is the risk of staying, what is the risk of changing? all decisions are risk versus risk. So some people look at life as I'm going to try to find something where there's no risk. Every option has a risk. So for example, if you put your money into a savings account and get close to 0% interest, the risk you take is you lose against inflation and you lose against the,
也许不如泰勒·斯威夫特那么伟大，但人不能拥有一切。所以，矛盾心理，即对矛盾心理的不耐受，助长了遗憾和反刍。在任何决策中，你知道的，人们会思考：留下的风险是什么？改变的风险是什么？所有的决定都是风险与风险的较量。因此，有些人把生活看作是一场试图寻找“零风险”的努力。但每一个选项都有风险。例如，如果你把钱存入储蓄账户，利率接近于 0%，你承担的风险是你敌不过通货膨胀，而且你失去了通过投资或购买债券、股票来赚钱的机会。
opportunity to make money if you invest it or put it in bonds, invested in equities. When you put it in equities, you run the risk that the stock market could crash. So there's risk versus risk. If you get married, there's a risk it won't work out. If you don't get married, there's a risk you'll be lonely or whatever. It's comparing the risk. It's not looking for a risk fee for your alternative. The other part of what leads people, I think, to have difficulty in making decisions is the degree to which we, you know, this is especially true with people who are depressed, the degree to which we tend to have a bias to predict negatives.
当你把钱投入股票时，你要承担股市崩盘的风险。所以这就是风险对风险。如果你结婚了，有婚姻不顺的风险；如果你不结婚，有孤独或其他什么的风险。这是对风险的比较，而不是去寻找一个毫无风险的替代方案。导致人们在做决定时遇到困难的另一个因素，我认为——对于那些抑郁的人来说尤其如此——是我们倾向于预测消极结果的偏见。
So I was talking with somebody who very, very smart and very successful, in fact, very wealthy, who keeps almost all his money. in, you know, CDs and money markets rather than investing in the stock market. Now, that might be good on occasion, but in the long term, that is probably not a good strategy. But like other things in this person's life, he was risk averse, you know, to do, should I leave my partner? Should I, you know, make this decision, whatever it is. So accepting reasonable risk is part of making decisions. And it's also part of living with the consequences. So if the consequences, one of the things that makes it hard for people and leads them to having more regret and rumination is the tendency they have to idealize the alternative and to discount what they have.
所以我曾和一个非常、非常聪明、非常成功，事实上也非常富有的人交谈过，他几乎把所有的钱都放在大额存单（CD）和货币市场基金里，而不是投资股市。现在，这在某些情况下可能是个好主意，但从长远来看，这可能并不是一个好策略。但就像这人生活中的其他事情一样，他是风险厌恶型的，你知道的，不管是“我应该离开伴侣吗？”还是“我应该做出这个决定吗？”等等。因此，接受合理的风险是决策的一部分。这也是与后果共存的一部分。所以，如果后果——让人们感到困难、导致他们产生更多遗憾和反刍的因素之一——是他们倾向于将替代方案理想化，并贬低他们当前所拥有的东西。
So, for example, people who regret my, oh, if I had married this other person or pursued this other career, you know, I would be so much happier. You know, I remember a few years ago thinking, you know, I know when I was in high school, everybody thought I was going to be a lawyer. I thought I was going to be a lawyer. But I decided to be a psychologist, and I'm pretty happy with that. But I thought, you know, maybe I should have been a lawyer, you know, and all that. And then I began thinking, gee, I know a lot of lawyers. And they have one of the highest rates of depression. And it's such an adversarial.
例如，那些感到后悔的人会想：“哦，如果我和另一个人结婚了，或者追求了另一种职业，我会幸福得多。”我记得几年前我想过：我知道我在高中时，每个人都以为我会成为一名律师。我自己也以为我会成为一名律师。但我决定成为一名心理学家，而且我对这个选择挺满意的。但我当时想，你知道的，也许我本该成为一名律师，等等。然后我开始想：天哪，我认识很多律师。他们的抑郁症发病率是最高的。而且这是一行如此充满对抗性的……
I'm not maligning lawyers, but I think for me being a psychologist has been a good choice. But we tend to idealize the alternatives. And people who regret often idealize the alternatives. They have the fear of missing out. Somebody recently published an article on the joy of missing out. So it's kind of like, yeah. It's another way to look at it. Thank God I'm not at that.
我不是在诋毁律师，但对我而言，成为一名心理学家是一个不错的选择。然而我们往往会把替代方案理想化。感到后悔的人经常将替代方案理想化。他们有“害怕错过”的心态。最近有人发表了一篇关于“错过的快乐”的文章。所以这就有点像……是的。这是另一种看待它的方式。感谢上帝，我没有在跨年夜午夜时分挤在 42 街。感谢上帝，我错过了那个。因此，人们倾向于把替代方案理想化，然后贬低自己拥有的一切。对抗“纠结于现有生活”的想法有几种方法，其中一种方法是想象如果你一无所有会怎样。
I'm not done on 42nd Street, 12 midnight New Year's Eve. Thank God I missed out on that. And so there's this sort of tendency to idealize the alternatives and then to discount what you have. One way of countering the idea of there's several ways. ways of countering the idea of living with what you have, is to imagine if you had nothing. So, and this is, I think, something that in an affluent and very ambitious society, we often don't spend enough time with gratitude. So, for example, I walk to my office. I live on the upper east side.
而且我认为，在一个富裕且极具野心的社会中，我们往往没有花足够的时间去心怀感恩。例如，我步行去办公室。我住在上东区。我的办公室在 58 街。即使我沿着第三大道走，我也会看到无家可归的人。我看到过一个无家可归的老年妇女推着一辆手推车之类的东西。有两种情绪可以对抗遗憾：一种是对那些一无所有的人产生同情心，
My office is on 58th Street. And even if I walk down Third Avenue, I'll see people who are homeless. I saw elderly woman who was homeless pushing a cart and stuff. And two emotions that can counter regret are one is compassion for somebody who has so little. and the other is gratitude for the fact that I'm actually able to walk down Third Avenue and go to a nice office and talk to you today. So it's kind of like we don't really have the kind of culture of gratitude. And one thing that's interesting, Kim, is that there's a search,
另一种是心怀感恩，感谢自己实际上能够走在第三大道上，去一间不错的办公室，今天还能跟你交谈。所以这有点像，我们其实缺乏一种感恩的文化。金，有一点很有趣，那就是有一个名为 Google Ngram 的搜索工具，你可以在 Google Ngram 中输入关键词，它会提供一个搜索引擎。在这个搜索引擎中，你可以输入一个词，看看在过去的 150 年里，这个词在印刷文本中被使用的频率如何。如果我们看一下“遗憾”（regret），从 1980 年到 2019 年，在英语印刷书籍和文件中，“遗憾”一词的使用频率出现了惊人的增长。在那期间发生了什么？经济不平等急剧加剧，完美主义急剧增加——根据从大约 1989 年到 2016 年进行的调查——
tool called Google Ngram that you can look, you can type in Google Ngram and you'll come up with a search engine. And on the search engine, you can type in a word and see how often that word is used in the printed language over the last 150 years. So if we look at regret, regret had an incredible increase in the frequency in English language printed books and documents between 1980 and 2019. And what happened during that time was a dramatic increase in economic inequality, a dramatic increase in perfectionism and surveys that were taken from like 1989 to 2016.
并且我认为，人们认为“我应该能够做到一切”的想法也大幅增加。因此，遗憾是“机会的情绪”。我们经常认为机会总是一件美妙的事情。但机会也会让你去想：“这个人这么成功，为什么我没有成功？为什么我没有变得超级富有或出名之类？”所以我们经历了这一切，我的意思是，从 1980 年代开始，这是一个戏剧性的增长。顺便说一句，你在西班牙文学和俄罗斯文学中也能发现同样的情况。
and a dramatic increase, I think, in the idea that I should be able to do everything. So regret is the opportunity emotion. And we often think that opportunity is always a wonderful thing. But opportunity also leads you to think, well, this person is so successful. Why am I not successful? Why am I not extremely wealthy or famous or whatever? So we have this, I mean, it's a dramatic increase in 1980 on. You find the same thing, by the way, in Spanish literature and in Russia.
因此，经济不平等、全球化、疏离感、完美主义，以及 20 年前开始兴起的社交媒体，都出现了这种急剧增长，社交媒体为你提供了社会比较的途径。有多少人在拿自己与第三大道上无家可归的老年妇女作比较？他们在拿自己跟埃隆·马斯克作比较，顺便说一句，他身家 2400 亿美元，但似乎并不是一个非常快乐的人。我的意思是，他们甚至在与同龄人作比较，但由于人们使用社交媒体的方式总是展示美好的一面：这是我昨晚吃的美味晚餐，这是我去度过的假期，而他们的生活可能一团糟，但你根本无从得知。没错，完全如此。是的，就像“凡尔赛文学”（谦虚地炫耀）。
So you have this dramatic increase in economic inequality, globalization, alienation, perfectionism, social media kicking in 20 years ago, where it gives you the social comparison. how many people are comparing themselves to the homeless elderly woman on Third Avenue? They're comparing themselves to Elon Musk, who, by the way, doesn't seem to be a very happy person with his $240 billion. But, I mean, they're even comparing themselves to their peers, but because people use social media in such a way as to always present something beautiful. This is the lovely dinner I had last night. This is the vacation I took, whereas their life might be miserable, but you don't know that. Right, exactly. Yeah, like the humble brag.
我真是太谦虚了。我太优秀了，正过着美好的时光。你知道的，我说：不，你一点也不谦虚。不过，让我顺便提一下“谦逊”。我在我的书《要是当前：如何摆脱遗憾的束缚》中描述的概念之一，就是我所说的“适应性谦逊”。这是谦逊文献中我非常喜欢的一个概念。适应性谦逊并不是说“我是一只应声虫，我不配得到任何东西”，整个……适应性谦逊不是那样的。适应性谦逊是：我只是另一个普通人。我并不
I'm so humbled. I'm so outstanding and having a wonderful time. You know, I said, no, you're not humble. But let me actually bring up humility. One of the concepts I describe in my book, if only, finding freedom from regret is what I call, you know, adaptive humility. And this is a concept in the literature on humility that I find very appealing. Adaptive humility is not, I'm a dormant and I deserve nothing and, you know, the whole, that's not what adaptive humility is. Adaptive humility is, I'm just another human being. I'm not
特殊。我不配得到任何特殊待遇。我会犯错，我会出错，我可以道歉。我们从关于谦逊的研究中得知，那些被认为具有谦逊品质的人、那些被视为真诚道歉的人，更能赢得信任，拥有更好的人际关系和友情，人们也更愿意与这样的人共事。我相信听到这里的很多人都能想到他们认识的某些人，他们从不道歉，你知道的。适应性谦逊意味着：我犯了错误，我说了一些不公平的话，我对此感到很糟糕。我想道歉。我希望你能接受我的道歉。但在某种意义上，你真的不能说“你欠我一个道歉”。你知道的，这就好比……
special. I don't deserve any special treatment. I can make mistakes. I can be wrong. I can apologize. And what we know is that from the research on humility, that people who are viewed as having humility, people who are viewed as sincerely apologizing, are trusted more, have better relationships, have better friendships, and people want to work with that. And I'm sure many people listening to this can think of people. they know who never apologize, you know. Adaptive humility is, you know, I'm, I made a mistake. I said something that wasn't fair. I really felt bad about that. I want to apologize. I hope you accept my apology. But in a sense, really, you can't say you owe me an apology. You know, it's kind of like,
仅仅索要道歉并不是购买道歉的货币。但适应性谦逊能让你带着错误生活，允许自己预见到错误，允许你建设性地利用遗憾，允许你对拥有的东西心存感激。我的意思是，我在一个贫困的经济适用房小区里长大。我的意思是，那是一个艰难的社区，但我并不是在美化贫困。但我认为这让我：第一，对那些拥有较少的人抱有同情心，不会对那些没有高地位职位的人抱有精英主义态度，把每个人都当作平等的人对待；第二，能够作为一个普通人生活，而不是作为一个高高在上的角色。
you know, simply asking for an apology is not. the currency to buy an apology. But adaptive humility allows you to live with mistakes, allows you to anticipate mistakes, allows you to use regret productively, allows you to have gratitude for what you have. I mean, I grew up very poor in a housing project. I mean, it was, you know, it was a tough neighborhood, but I'm not glamorizing poverty. But I think it led me to, one, to have compassion for people who have less, not to be an elitist with people who don't have, like, you know, high status positions to treat everybody as an equal. to, you know, to be able to live as a human being, not as some character above the crowd.
在你的工作中，你谈到了关于遗憾的“沉没成本效应”。你这是什么意思？我们如何克服这种成本来做出更好的选择，以便我们在未来能减少遗憾？是的，所以沉没成本效应，我想我们所有人都能对此产生共鸣。比如你买了一样东西，花了很多钱，你买了一件衣服、夹克什么的，你穿了一次，把它挂进衣橱里，一挂就是五十年。你和你的伴侣说：“你为什么不把它扔掉呢？鲍勃，这件夹克你已经 10 年没穿了，你知道吗？”
In your work, you talk about the sunk cost effect when it comes to regret. What do you mean by that? And how can we overcome that cost to make better choices so that we might have fewer regrets in the future? Yeah, so the sunk cost effect, I think we all can identify with this. And like you buy something, you spend a lot of money, you buy a dress or a jacket or whatever, and you wear it once, you put it in your closet and it's there for five or ten years. And you were your partner and say, you know, why don't you throw that out? You know, you haven't worn that jacket, Bob, in 10 years, you know?
“哦，我花了不少好钱买的呢，对吧？”所以这是一个沉没成本。换句话说，我已经投入了成本。我已经花了好钱买下了它。但现在它对我已经没有用了，因为我根本不穿它。我只是在自欺欺人。而且，它还占着衣橱里的空间。另外，我本可以把它送给其他能用得上它的人。
Oh, I paid good money for it, right? So it's a sunk, it's what's called a sunk cost. In other words, I've already put the cost in. I've already paid the good money. But now it's not useful to me because I'm not using it. And I'm only kidding myself. And plus, it's taking up room in the closet. Plus, I could give it away to somebody else who could use it.
但是人类是唯一会陷入沉没成本陷阱的生物。我的意思是，猫、狗、昆虫、鸟类、猴子，它们才不会去试图为自己过去的决定辩护。它们不会说：“嗯，我要把这根香蕉留着接下来的五个月，因为我为了得到这根香蕉付出了很多努力。”当香蕉不再有用时，它们就会转向别的东西。但人类是有反思能力的。我们想要让我们的决定显得合情合理。
But we have, humans are the only living creature that gets trapped by some costs. I mean, cats and dogs and insects and birds, monkeys, they're not trying to justify. five their past decisions. They're not saying, well, I'm going to hold on to that banana for the next five months because, you know, I worked hard to get that banana. When it's no longer useful, they move on to something else. But humans are self-reflective. We want to make sense of our decisions.
我们觉得：“哦，如果我把那件衣服扔掉，我会后悔的。我会想念它的。我会觉得浪费的。”你知道的，我的意思是，我在开研讨会时使用的一个练习是：让我们想象我举起一张 100 美元的钞票。我说：“你知道的，我不会把这钱花在自己身上。我也不会把它给任何人。但我想要做的是在大家面前把它烧掉。好吗？”
We think that, oh, if I throw that piece of clothing out, I'm going to regret it. I'll miss it. I'll be wasting. You know, I mean, one exercise I use when I give workshops is, let's imagine I hold up a $100 bill. And I said, you know, I'm not going to spend this on myself. I'm not going to give this to anybody. But what I'd like to do is burn it in front of people. All right?
大多数看到我把它烧掉的人都会对我很生气，因为他们不想看到我浪费一张 100 美元的钞票。我们不想……这就好像你 10 岁时你妈妈对你说：“把盘子里的东西全吃光。你知道世界上其他地方还有人在挨饿呢。”这就是人类关于“浪费”和“遗憾”的心态。那么你该如何处理沉没成本呢？例如，你可能会对一段关系或一项职业产生沉没成本。你知道的，有些人刚开始从事某项职业，几年后却恨透了它。
Most people watching me burn it would be really angry with me because they don't want to see me wasting a $100 bill. And we don't, you know, it's like when your mother says to you and you're 10 years old, eat everything on your plate. You know, there are people somewhere else in the world starving. You know, it's this human thing about wasting and regret. So what can you do with the sunk costs? Like, for example, you can have sunk costs about a relationship or a career. You know, some people start out a career and they hate it after a few years.
然后他们说：“哦，我不能放弃它，因为我进行了好几年的培训。我不能抛弃这一切。”这就是沉没成本。问题是：未来它会有用吗？它会有乐趣和意义吗？当我离开学术界去追求临床职业时，我的一位同事的丈夫说：“鲍勃要离开学术界和研究领域了。一个优秀的大脑就这样浪费了。”我想他也许有道理。我当时应该听他的。
And they say, oh, I can't give it up because I put several years of training. I can't walk away from all that. That's the sunk cost. The question is, is the future going to be useful and is it going to be pleasurable and meaningful? When I left academics because I wanted to pursue a clinical career, the husband of one of my colleagues said, Bob is leaving academics and research. What a waste of a good mind. And I think maybe he had a point. I should have listened to him.
但是，你知道的，这就好比我们觉得我们必须为自己过去的投资辩护。例如，人们会死死抓着一只股票不放，说：“嗯，我花 100 美元买的这只股票。它跌到了 60 美元。它会涨回来的。”不，你的钱已经死了并上了天堂。你知道的，它不会回来了。它不会复活的。去墓地吧，让你的投资安息吧。
But, you know, it's sort of like the idea that we have to justify our past investment. You know, for example, people will hold on to a stock and say, well, I paid $100 for the stock. It went down to 60. It'll come back. No, your money died and went to heaven. You know, it's not coming back. It's not going to be resurrected. They go to the cemetery, rest in peace.
但是，这是人类会做的事情。所以我们应该思考的是：第一，这东西未来的效用是什么？我保留它的成本是什么？好处是什么？第二，就像一段关系一样，如果我在这段糟糕的关系中再呆一年，我会错过什么机会？如果我呆在一段糟糕的婚姻里或其他什么地方，我会错过寻找新关系的机会，或者错过独自生活的快乐机会。我会错过避免与伴侣争吵的机会。所以我们要考虑机会成本。我们要思考那种试图为过去辩护而不是努力让未来变得更好的错误。
your investment. So, but it's, it's something that humans do. So what we should think about, one is, what is the future utility of this? You know, what is the cost of my keeping it? What is the benefit? Second, like with a relationship, if I stay in this bad relationship for another year, what opportunities will I miss? If I stay in a bad marriage or whatever, I'll miss the opportunity of finding a new relationship or the opportunity of being happy on my own. I'll miss the opportunity of not having arguments with my partner. So we think about opportunity costs. We think about the error of trying to justify the past rather than trying to make the future
因此，你的决定应该永远关乎未来的自我和未来的效用。但我们经常会想：“好吧，别人看着我会觉得：‘哦，真是个白痴，他或她浪费了那么多时间。’”我认为当人们看到你摆脱一种糟糕的状况时，他们往往会觉得：“嗯，早该这样了。干得好。”但如果他们不这么想，那算什么朋友？
better. So your decision should always be about the future self and future utility. But we often think, well, people look at me and think, oh, what an idiot, you know, he wasted or she wasted all that time. I think when people see you getting out of a bad situation, they often think, well, it's about time. You know, good for you. But if they don't, what kind of friend is that?
如果他们希望你继续呆在糟糕的状况里的话。另一件事是：你会给别人什么建议？金，我们在告诉别人“赶快离开那段关系吧”或者“换个职业、换个工作”之类的事情时，真的是非常、非常在行。我们非常擅长告诉别人做出改变，因为我们不需要为他们的决定辩护。这不是——这就像认知失调。我们不需要向他们解释他们为什么会做出那个决定。
If they want you to stay in a bad situation. The other thing is, what advice would you give to somebody else? So we're really, really good, Kim, at telling other people, get the hell out of that relationship, you know, or, you know, change your career or change your job or, you know, whatever. We're really good at telling people to make a change because we don't have to justify their decision. It's not, this is like cognitive dissonance. We don't have to justify for them why they made that decision, you know.
所以，是的，沉没成本是非常强大的。你的猫、你的狗或者你养的任何宠物，或者是鸟儿什么的，它们才不会坐在那里反刍琢磨：“别的鸟或猫会怎么看我？这证明了我是一个糟糕的决策者。”据我们所知，它们不会这样做。我将无法进入我心仪的大学。猫只有四种认知：
So, yeah, the sunk cost is very powerful. And your cat or your dog or whatever pets you have or, you have. or birds or whatever, they're not, you know, sitting there ruminating about, what will other birds or cats think of me? This proves I'm a bad decision maker. As far as we know, they're not doing that. I won't be able to get into the college of my choice. Cats only have four cognitions.
这感觉很好。这感觉不好。我要那个，接下来是什么。为了稍微转换一下话题，让我问你这个：遗憾在生命的早期是如何显现的？儿童从什么年龄开始感到遗憾？随着年龄的增长，这种情况会发生变化吗？是的。
This feels good. This doesn't feel good. I want that and what's next. So to shift gears a little bit here, let me ask you this. How early in life does regret manifest? What age do children begin to feel regret? And does that change as they get older? Yeah.
所以这很有趣。孩子们在四岁到七岁之间开始表现出遗憾的迹象，而那些表达出遗憾的孩子被证明更擅长做决定，因为他们能从错误中吸取教训或预见到错误。其次，他们更擅长调节自己的情绪，因为他们会想：“如果我以这种方式行事，也许我会后悔。或者如果我这样做，我的情绪会失控。”当人们接近生命终点时——当你看看那些可能在一个月或几个月内就要去世的人的遗憾——他们不会有什么遗憾：
So it's interesting. The kids begin showing evidence of regret between the ages of four and seven. and the kids who express regret turn out to be better at making decisions because they learn from their mistakes or they anticipate mistakes. Second, they're better at regulating their emotions because they think, well, if I act out in this way, maybe I'll regret it. Or if I do this, my emotions will become dysregulated. As people get toward the end of life, when you look at the regrets of people in how, People who may be dying in the next month or a few months, whatever. They're not having regrets.
“我希望我花更多时间刷社交媒体”或者“我希望我在圣诞季结束时买到了布鲁明戴尔百货公司的特价商品”。他们才不会想这些。他们表达的遗憾是：我希望自己对自己的情感更真实一点；我希望我曾对人们说过我爱他们；我希望我曾追求过自己真正想做的事情，基本上就是根据我的价值观和人际关系来生活。我认为，当人们接近生命终点时，聆听他们的话是很重要的一课。
I wish I spent more time on social media or I wish I got the bargains at Bloomingdale's at the end of the Christmas season. They're not thinking about that. The regrets that they expressed, I wish it had been more true to my emotions. I wish I had told people I love them. I wish I had pursued things I really wanted to do and basically living. according to my values and according to the human relationships. And I think that's an important thing to listen to people as they get toward the end of life.
他们学到了很多，对于什么才重要拥有许多智慧。因此，如果你看看安宁疗护中人们的遗憾，这就是我们所看到的。我们看不到对物质主义、地位和证明自己、赢得争论的执着，老年人的遗憾清单里没有这些。事实上，老年人有一种“积极性偏差”。他们可能会有更多长期的遗憾，因为他们已经活了很长时间。但在日常生活中，他们更容易让自己与遗憾保持距离。他们只是向前看。
What they've learned, they have a lot of wisdom about what matters. And so if you look at the regrets of people in hospice, that's what we see. We don't see materialism and status and, you know, proving, winning argument. that's not in the regret repertoire of elderly people. In fact, elderly people have a positivity bias. They may have more long-term regrets because they've been around for a long time. But on a day-to-day basis, they're more easily distanced themselves from regrets. They just kind of move on.
好吧，上周的事情没成功。我要继续往前走，每一天都是一份礼物。男性和女性体验遗憾的方式不同吗？所以男性和女性——再次说明，随着性别角色变得越来越融合，我认为这一点将会改变。研究显示，男性在成就和物质主义方面有更多遗憾，而女性在人际关系以及在恋爱关系中过早发生性行为方面有更多遗憾。话虽如此，男女之间其实有很多相同的遗憾。当我们观察文化差异时，美国人在浪漫、学校、教育和职业方面有更多遗憾，而亚洲文化中的人们，比如在台湾或日本，
All right, so that didn't work out last week. I'm going to move on, you know, every day's gift. Do men and women experience regret differently? So men and women, and again, I think this is going to change as gender roles become more integrated, let's say. Men have more regrets in the research about achievement and materialism, and women have more regrets about relationships and having sex too early in a relationship, having sex too early in a relationship, having said that, men and women have a lot of the same regrets. When we look at cultural differences, Americans have more regrets about romance, about school, about education, career, whereas people in Asian culture, like in Taiwan or Japan,
更有可能对家庭、人际关系以及人际事物感到遗憾。这里有很多重叠。这并不是非此即彼的。所以这有点像去思考你的遗憾到底意味着什么。它们对你说了些什么？但我认为，回到你之前提到的那点，金，我确实认为社交媒体使得遗憾往往与社会比较挂钩。虽然不总是这样，但它经常与诸如“看看那个人……”联系在一起。
and more likely to have regrets about family and about relationships and about interpersonal things. There's a lot of overlap. It's not like either or. So it's kind of like thinking about what your regrets are all about. What do they say to you about it? But I think going back to what you mentioned earlier, Kim, I do think that social media, that regret is often tied into social comparison. Not always, but it's often tied into, well, look at that person.
我曾有一位患者，他在职业生涯中做得相当不错，但赚的钱不多，积累的财富也没有他大学同学那么多，于是他为自己的现状感到遗憾，或者产生嫉妒之类的。但我说：“好吧，让我们看看你究竟拥有什么。”他与伴侣的关系很好，与孩子们的关也系很好。他很健康。他是个好人。我说：“你觉得会不会有人在嫉妒你呢？”
They had a patient who, you know, was, you know, doing fairly well in his career, but was not making as much, had not accumulated as much wealth as people he went to college with and, you know, regretting, you know, where he was or having envy and whatever. But I said, well, let's look at what you do have. And he had a great relationship with his partner, great relationship with his kids. He's healthy. He's a good person. And I said, do you think there would be people who would be envious of you?
他们曾有一个病人，你知道的，在事业上发展得还算不错，但挣的钱没有大学同学那么多，积累的财富也没有那么多，你知道的，他为自己的现状感到后悔，或者心生嫉妒之类的。但我说，好吧，让我们看看你拥有什么。他与伴侣的关系很好，与孩子们的关系也很好。他很健康。他是个好人。我说，你觉得会不会有人嫉妒你呢？
So we often don't think that when we regret things, we don't think, gee, a lot of people might be envious of me. So it's a paradox, I think, that, you know, the social comparison, I think, should be geared to gratitude and compassion. And I've never met somebody. Maybe these people never go to therapy, but I've never met somebody who said, you know, Dr. Leahy, you've really got to help me because I have too much gratitude and compassion. You know, I don't know, it's getting the best of me. Yeah, we got to change that. You know, on the other hand, I know someone who likes to tell people that she regrets no choices that she ever made in her life, which I find really hard to believe. Do you encounter, are there really such people who say, yeah, everything I did?
所以我们经常不会想到，当我们感到后悔时，我们不会觉得，天哪，很多人可能会嫉妒我。所以我觉得这是一个悖论，你知道，社会比较，我认为应该导向感恩和同情。我从来没见过这样的人。也许这些人从不去心理治疗，但我从未见过有人说，你知道，莱希博士，你真的得帮帮我，因为我有太多的感恩和同情。你知道，我不知道，这让我有点应接不暇。是的，我们必须改变这一点。你知道，另一方面，我认识一个人，她喜欢告诉别人，她对她一生中所做的任何选择都不后悔，我觉得这很难让人相信。你遇到过吗，真的有这样的人会说，是的，我做的一切都……
I was great. Yeah, right. Yeah. I say nonsense. You know, it's like you're looking in the wrong mirror. You know, and I think that's part of like our contemporary social meme, you know, I have no regrets because every decision I made was mine and I live with the consequences. How are you going to learn from your mistakes? Why would you ever apologize if you don't have regrets, right?
我很棒。是的，没错。是的。我说这简直是无稽之谈。你知道，这就好像你在照一面错误的镜子。你知道，我认为这是我们当代社会迷因的一部分，你知道，我毫不后悔，因为我做的每一个决定都是我自己的，我承担所有的后果。你将如何从错误中吸取教训？如果你不感到后悔，你又怎么会道歉呢，对吧？
I mean, imagine you were looking for a life partner, right? You're looking for a life partner and you meet somebody and they say, oh, I really like you, they attracted to you. you're a wonderful person, but I think you need to know something about me. I'm incapable of regret and apology, right? Not unlike some politicians. So, you know, well, I don't know. For a lot of people, that might be a red flag because, you know, you want people who have some regrets and some apologies.
我的意思是，想象一下你在寻找生活伴侣，对吧？你在寻找生活伴侣，你遇到一个人，他们说，哦，我真的很喜欢你，他们被你吸引。你是一个很棒的人，但我认为你需要了解我的一件事。我不会感到后悔和道歉，对吧？这和某些政客没什么两样。所以，你知道，好吧，我不知道。对很多人来说，这可能是一个危险信号，因为，你知道，你希望人们会感到一些后悔并进行一些道歉。
That's how you heal relationships. Are there any big areas in this aspect of psychology? that you feel are under research that we still need to know answers about? Well, I think that, I mean, I think we really need to look at a lot of cultural issues and regret, a lot of LBGQT issues and regret. And there's some recent research on that, like gender affirming surgery. Only 1% of patients who have that express regret. despite what the critics may say of transgender and gender affirming, only 1%, whereas people who have cosmetic surgery, a significant percentage have regrets.
这就是你修复关系的方式。在心理学这个领域，有没有什么你觉得研究还不够深入、我们仍然需要了解答案的重大领域？嗯，我觉得，我的意思是，我觉得我们真的需要研究很多文化问题和后悔，很多LGBTQ问题和后悔。并且有一些关于这方面的最新研究，比如性别肯定手术。只有1%接受过该手术的患者表示后悔。尽管批评跨性别和性别肯定手术的人可能会说三道四，但只有1%，而做整容手术的人中，有相当大一部分会感到后悔。
So, you know, are you more likely to have regret about a nose job than a transgender? Yes, by factors, by many factors, right? So, yeah, so, you know, the facts can often confuse your thinking. But, yeah, so I think we need to really look at a lot of the cultural and demographic differences and group differences in regret. And then how people spontaneously deal with regret. I mean, a lot of times, if you're a therapist, you listen to a patient and you think, gee, that's a great idea. I wish I thought of it. And then you realize, yeah, my wife has been telling me that for five years.
所以，你知道，你对隆鼻手术感到后悔的可能性是否比对跨性别手术更大？是的，从倍数来看，从很多方面来看，对吧？所以，是的，所以，你知道的事实往往会混淆你的思维。但是，是的，所以我认为我们确实需要审视很多关于后悔的文化、人口统计学差异以及群体差异。然后人们如何自发地处理后悔。我的意思是，很多时候，如果你是一名治疗师，你听患者倾诉，你会想，天哪，这主意真棒。我怎么没想到呢。然后你意识到，是的，我妻子五年来一直这么对我说。
Why am I more likely to listen to a patient than my partner? You know, so a lot of times people come up with their spontaneous cures or strategies or techniques. Therapists don't have a monopoly on wisdom. And question, even if they have any wisdom, but they don't have a monopoly on it. So looking at how people make the best of what they have. And what I'm struck by, I'm not a religious person. I was raised Catholic, but I'm not practicing anything. But I had a Orthodox Jewish patient who said, he said, you know, Bob, you know the
为什么我听患者的话的概率比听伴侣的话的概率更高？你知道，所以很多时候人们会想出他们自发的治疗方法、策略或技巧。治疗师并不垄断智慧。而且问题是，即使他们有什么智慧，他们也没有垄断它。因此，要看看人们如何充分利用他们所拥有的东西。让我印象深刻的是，我不是一个有宗教信仰的人。我是在天主教环境中长大的，但我什么都不践行。但我有一个正统犹太患者，他说，他说，你知道，鲍勃，你知道那个
musso that right outside the threshold of the door you see in apartments in New York. I touched that when I leave the apartment to remind me of God's president. throughout the day. Even though I'm not a believer, I thought, what a beautiful reminder of gratitude and humility to take throughout the day. And I don't think you have to be
门框右侧的门楣经匣，你在纽约的公寓里能看到。我离开公寓时会摸一下它，以此提醒我上帝的同在贯穿整天。尽管我不是信徒，但我心想，这是对感恩和谦逊多么美好的提醒，可以伴随我们整天。而且我认为你不必成为
like a Zen warrior to think this way. But I think there's a lot to be said for recognizing life has tradeoffs. You're never going to get everything you want on your terms. So forget about demanding it. Be flexible about your expectations. Recognize your mind is not going to be pure mind.
像个禅宗武士一样去这样思考。但我认为，认识到生活需要权衡取舍，这很有道理。你永远不可能完全按照你的条件得到你想要的一切。所以不要再去强求了。对你的期望保持灵活性。认识到你的大脑不会是纯粹的心灵。
It's going to be a kaleidoscope filled with noise. And you can be ambivalent about your partner for the rest of your life and still have a good relationship because all your friends who know you are ambivalent about you because they know you. And that's that to me is living in the real world. And regret is always about a fictional world. It's about what psychologists call a counterfactual world. What does counterfactual mean against the facts? It means it's not a fact. It's what you think could be.
它将是一个充满噪音的万花筒。你余生都可以对你的伴侣抱有矛盾的情感，并且依然拥有一段美好的关系，因为所有了解你的人对你也抱有矛盾的情感，因为他们了解你。对我而言，这就是生活在真实世界中。而后悔总是关于一个虚构的世界。它是关于心理学家所说的反事实世界。什么是反事实？就是与事实相反。这意味着它不是事实。它是你认为可能存在的东西。
It's a possibility emotion as opposed to living in the real world and making the best of what you have while still trying to do better. It doesn't mean you are resigned and give up. You can always do better. You can always grow. But we often do recognize how fortunate we are until we talk to people living in other parts of the world who are suffering or see people who are disabled and struggling just to get down the street and to live. Dr. Leahy, I want to thank you for chatting with me today. I found this to be very interesting and informative. And I think that our listeners will learn a great deal from it.
这是一种可能性情绪，而不是生活在真实世界中，在努力做得更好的同时，充分利用你所拥有的东西。这并不意味着你逆来顺受、放弃努力。你总是可以做得更好。你总能成长。但我们往往没有意识到自己有多幸运，直到我们与生活在世界其他地方正在受苦的人交谈，或者看到那些残疾并为了走过街道和生活而挣扎的人。莱希博士，我想感谢你今天与我聊天。我发现这次谈话非常有趣且信息量巨大。而且我认为我们的听众会从中学到很多。
Thank you. Well, Kim, thank you so much for having me. I really sincerely appreciate your having me on. I hope you have a great day. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.combeingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology
谢谢。好的，金，非常感谢你邀请我。我真的非常感谢你能邀请我上节目。祝你今天过得愉快。谢谢。您可以在我们的网站 www.apa.org/news/podcasts/speaking-of-psychology 上找到“心理学谈话”往期节目，也可以在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方收听。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以给我们发送电子邮件，邮箱是 speakingofpsychology
at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinemann. Our sound editor is Chris Condiion. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·维内曼（Lee Weinemann）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪翁（Chris Condiion）。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学会。该期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。